passible marina orsini kova affrontait
une nouvelle fois la justice russe cette
journaliste a été déclaré coupable de
propos qui discrédite l'armée russe
selon la justice
incompréhensible pour elle qui avait
réagi avant même le verdict je ne
comprends pas du tout comment je
pourrais discréditer l'armée en disant
que la guerre est le plus grand crime du
21e siècle toutes les accusations sont
absurdes et le verdict sera un
acquittement en mars dernier c'est elle
qui avait interrompu le journal télévisé
de la chaîne d'état de chanel ou à nous
elle travaillait sur sa pancarte des
slogans anti gouvernement non à la
guerre ne croyait pas à la propagande on
vous ment ici des images qui ont fait le
tour du monde et lui avait valu une
arrestation de courte durée libérée elle
s'était réfugié en allemagne où elle
avait continué de travailler et de
porter son message très personnel elle
qui est née en ukraine mais a grandi en
pitié
la guerre en ukraine a été l'élément
déclencheur pour moi
des images de mon enfance me sont
revenus je ne pouvais que ressentir ce
que ces malheureuses ukrainien traverse
c'était trop pour moi
mais depuis marina ovsyannikov a fait
débat en ukraine on la soupçonne d'être
une espionne à la solde du kremlin et en
russie elle est devenue persona non
grata pas de quoi la museler encore
mi-juillet à elle manifestait à moscou
sur sa pancarte ce message
poutine est un meurtrier
des prises de positions passibles de
sanctions pour ses propos discréditant
l'armée elle a écopé d'une amende de 50
mille roubles un peu plus de 800 dollars
les peines peuvent aller jusqu'à 15 ans
de prison